[Musique]
je suis dans une situation très
particulière le compte à rebours vient
de commencer de d'être un orateur ce
qu'on nous appelle les orateurs depuis
toutes les personnes qui sont venues ici
sont des orateurs dont je suis et
novateur il faut que je me mette dans la
place d'un orateur en général j'ai
plutôt la place du chanteur qui de temps
en temps se permet de parler de dire des
choses pas trop parce que quelquefois ou
lui dit chante que ce soir si je parle
trop vous ne tirez pas voilà c'est ça
non non vous ne le dira c'est ça vous ne
direz pas chante aussi donc je vais
essayer de vous dire des choses qui me
sont importantes jeu je suis devant une
espèce de grand panorama qui est ma vie
et qui comporte bien bien des choses des
anecdotes des pensées des prises de
position personnelles à -20 et des joies
des souffrances alors après il faut
refaire quelque chose peut-être voulu
dire d'une manière un peu
[Musique]
mais les chansons sont pas très pudique
sauf que dans une chanson on enlève la
date on enlève les lieux on enlève les
noms et ça devient les vôtres
[Musique]
aidons
ne se
si blanc
q
m
je souhaite
encore que
ce
oh
wen
station
sortir un peu
je suis
[Musique]
oui
metric
suite au porteur que
sens
[Musique]
son
il nous
l'enjeu
oui
ce
malou
les choses que je
son tout
[Musique]
jeanne mance
hh
je
comment
ce
moi
[Musique]
oh
ça c'était une première chance
quitte à rideaux
de plus
merci
[Applaudissements]
qui était allé vers l'oreille de plus de
gens que ma famille mes amis proches et
j'ai été très étonné après une grand
labyrinthe pour arriver à l'enregistrer
c'était très quelque chose une histoire
une saga mais quand il est arrivé à être
connue que j'ai vu que des gens
personnes se s'émouvait sur cette
chanson c'est une grande leçon pour moi
parce que je me suis aperçu ce moment là
que un miracle s'opérait parce que quand
on est adolescent on pense que quand on
est incompris puis après les années pas
si on continue à penser qu'on est
incompris qu'on est seul au monde
et puis on fait une chanson qui parle
d'une chose très très personnelle ma
rencontre avec la capitale de mon
enfance à l'âge adulte la capitale du
pays de mon enfance à l'âge adulte et
ceux qui écoutaient situant son le
connaissez peut-être pas madrid enfin
connaissez le nom de madrid mais pas
lille y être jamais allé sans y être
accusé et ensuite ils recevaient je
pense quelque chose qui un peu de
l'ordre de la deûle étrange familiarité
des lieux qu'on a aimé dans lesquels on
a été bons on se reconnaît mais on se
reconnaît plus on n'y est plus donc la
nostalgie qui en découle donc c'est de
ce sentiment a été pour moi celui qui
nous a rapprochés entre les personnes
qui ont écouté et aimé cette source
ensuite s'est installée immédiatement
quelque chose de très particulier qui
chaque fois qu on rencontre quelqu'un
j'ai besoin qu'on rencontre qu'on a
quelque chose ou qu'on acquiert quelque
chose que quelque chose arrive on a
immédiatement une peur qui s'installe
c'est la peur de perdre et j'ai détecté
ça très très vite je me suis aperçu que
le succès arrive et que ensuite
s'installe autour de soi et en soi le
désir de garder ça
de s'asseoir là-dessus et puis du coup
ce qui est arrivé d'une manière un peu
fortuite quand même miraculeuse on va
dire devient une inquiétude et devient
quelque chose qui ne nous rend plus
heureux j'ai observé un peu autour de
moi mes collègues les aînés qui était
passé par là et j'ai vu que leur visage
était triste quand il y avait pas les
caméras les préoccupations parce que la
peur de perdre
alors je me suis dit la peur de perdre
finalement qu'on a tous une femme on
aime un homme et on a peur de le perdre
on a des enfants on a peur de les perdre
on a une belle maison une maison tout
simplement la peur de la perdre
un travail on a peur de le perdre et à
la fin à la fin des fins arrive la perte
totale ou quelqu'un dit bon maintenant
tu vas tout perdre puisque c'est le
destin de l'humain de l'être humain tu
perdras tout alors je me suis dit en
face de cette perte la tant pis je
risque
cette perte du succès je risque et je me
suis fait des antidotes tu continues à
prendre le métro
on me disait mais non tu es une star
maintenant tu dois pas prendre le métro
sinon mon nom dans le métro une tu ne me
contrôle pas donc j'ai continué à faire
une vie comme ça normal j'ai voyagé j'ai
beaucoup voyagé je suis parti en
laissant ici des années de pendant des
années j'étais parti en argentine
beaucoup je partis en russie beaucoup
j'ai même vécu et tout ça ça m'a permis
aussi que quelque chose se remettent en
jeu que je ne sois pas dans un
simplement dans un fonds de commerce que
je perpétue ou que je travaille toujours
et 7
ce voyage c'est où était ma survie la
survie artistique parce que du coup je
me suis jamais vraiment là c'est j'ai
continué à aimer chanter sans avoir peur
sans avoir peur le demander s'il faut
toujours plaire si ça va plaire si ça va
rapporter des sous silva ça va pour en
rapporter ici et
que
à coeur
e
ça
c'est
[Musique]
à temps
c
e
g
vraiment
passion
pourtant
je n'ai mal
le
dans les interviews on m'a souvent
demandé pourquoi tu chantes pourquoi
vous chantez pourquoi vous êtes devenu
musicien chanteur
alors chaque fois j'ai trouvé une raison
j'ai acheté une guitare quand on a 14
ans avec mon père je mon père chantait
j'ai commencé à aimer telle ou telle eux
disent que tout ça c'était des raisons
et c'était pas des raisons les raisons
explicable un journaliste qui a envie
d'être compris quand il rapporte
l'interview mais je me suis aperçu que
les vraies raisons sont beaucoup plus
intime beaucoup plus caché difficile
même à soi-même de l'est de les
retrouver et je dois dire que que ces
raisons elles sont dans l'enfance par
exemple dans l'enfance dont la division
la vision de mon de la maison de mes
grands parents qui se trouvaient sur les
hauteurs de barcelone
les grands parents maternels qui se
trouvaient sur des hauteurs de barcelone
et d'où je voyais encore à cette époque
je pouvais voir la mer l'année à cet
horizon enfin l'horizon de la mer c'est
un peu loin et je voyais l'horizon puis
quelques fois le petit navire qui qui se
détachaient et cet horizon je crois
qu'une vision d'enfance aux visions pour
un enfant de cet horizon cc c'est toute
une vie coincé
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière je veux
aller là je vais aller là est derrière
cet horizon il y aura d'autres horizons
et un autre horizon donc les visions
d'enfance sont quand même très
importante c'est pour ça qu'au si je
pense que aux enfants il faut leur
offrir la possibilité d'avoir des
visions des visions des autres factions
des sensations et leur éviter la
télévisio pour les tablettes qui elle ne
donne pas de vision donc les visions
nous guide
ensuite parce que c'est là que la vérité
lorca disait j'écris aujourd'hui ce que
j'ai fait pendant
france pendant une enfance nous ne rêve
pas l'enfant ne rêve pas il fait il fait
dans sa tête il fait les bâtis ils
voyagent ils bougent et donc ses visions
d'enfance meute à mener a certainement
avoir besoin de connaître connaître
j'ai passé une frontière avec ma mère on
avait six ans je me suis aperçu que dès
qu'on passe une frontière ou les avait
tous de passer une frontière c'est une
autre frontière sunnite frontières et le
monde est à nous et ce sont les hommes
qui nous mettent des murs des êtres
humains nos semblables mais nous quand
on a passé une frontière on s'aperçoit
que d'autres choses existent c'est
important pour un enfant donc 7,7 ce
besoin de connaissances que j'ai reçues
quand j'étais enfant je lui aussi
reporté quand j'étais un peu adulte à 18
ans j'avais une prof de philo tout à
l'heure philippe été nous a expliqué
qu'il était prof de philo les profs de
philo elles peuvent être des gens très
importants et il m'a fait elle nous a
fait des cures fabuleux et un des cours
dans un des cours j'ai lu que nous a
fait lire un texte de philosophe
allemand qui s'appelle nietzsche lecce
et les amants et dans ce ce court
extrait il y avait une phrase les
chrétiens la fin de
vous pourrez dire les gens qui ont des
croyances 10 jeux que je ne me trompe
pas 10 je ne peux je ne veux pas je ne
veux pas tandis qu'il devrait dire je ne
peux pas et ils commencent à ce monde
hier donc pour moi c'était une
révélation je me suis dit à 18 ans alors
on ne peut passer sa vie à se mentir à
se raconter à soi même des salades à ce
s'imaginer quelqu'un d'autre et nos
actes et nos pensées et nos décisions
les fondé sur un mensonge personnel donc
ça a été pour moi aussi cette ce déclic
où j'ai décidé que ma vie ne serait le
moins possible consacré à ce mensonge à
ce même c'est à dire que quand on se
ment à soi-même ou fausse la balance
quand on ment aux autres c'est comme le
boucher qui met un papier un peu lourd
sous le sous la viande pour bon gagner
quelques grammes ou quelques
milligrammes
mais quand on se ment à ce même c'est la
balance qu'on a faut c'est donc après on
s'y retrouve plus et les mensonges qu'on
se faire les mensonges coup nous fait
tout devient un amalgame dangereux et on
peut partir sur la route de la vie de
cette manière là donc j'ai essayé je
pense le plus possible de ne pas de ne
pas aller dans cette direction
je sais pas si j'ai le temps pour
raconter une petite anecdote
[Musique]
tous
qui poussait
[Musique]
niveau
je
je chante et ça dans un cirque une
émission de télévision il y avait
derrière moi les pensionnaires du cirque
sont les éléphants même une dizaine et
ses éléphants avaient tous un anneau des
éléphants adultes avec tous un anneau la
cheville qui était relié nulle part avec
une chaîne qui traînait quand j'ai fini
la chanson j'ai demandé au trésor où
quelqu'un du circuit mais qu'est ce que
c'est cet anneau qui va nulle part dire
c'est que aujourd'hui il serait trop
difficile de les attacher il faut un
baobab à chaque fois mais quand ils sont
petits ou les entraves avec sa
réellement avec un pieu et comme
l'éléphant ensuite grandi avec cette
idée qu avec l'anneau il y entre à fait
d'une mouche plus même adulte est là
pour moi ça a été quelque chose de
terrible une une image terrible de ce
que l'être humain bien sûr fait aux
éléphants ce qui est déjà pas mal mais
ce qu'il fait aussi aux enfants ce qu'on
se fait à soi même ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on nous a fait ce qu'on nous ce que
nous on va faire aux autres et cette
image terrible mam révélé une grande
vérité qu'il faut mettre comme un
postulat de la vie nous sommes libres on
a passé beaucoup d'énergie nos parents
nous mêmes quand on élève des enfants
passent beaucoup d'énergie à faire
croire que l'on a les îles et les bras
derrière on n'a pas plus les bras
derrière qu'on est esclave
on est juste conditionnée à être cela
donc je vous remercie pour votre votre
écoute et puis je voudrais vous laissez
simplement cette cette phrase que
dostoïevski a prononcé qui magnifique
c'est non il l'a écrite quand il avait
aussi 18 ans et il disait l'être humain
est une énigme
il n'appelle pas encore écrit son oeuvre
l'être humain est une énigme et si moi
je passe ma vie à essayer de la résoudre
je n'aurais pas perdu mon temps voilà
[Applaudissements]